all right the squalid pictures uh just
can't get keep getting worse thousands
of migrants living as you can see right
there camped out in a massive tent city
under that bridge in
del rio texas our next guest knows the
area well rosindo inohosa served as
border chief patrol agent in the rio
grande valley sector and he joins us
from down in texas good morning to you
rosindo
good morning steve how you doing i'm
doing okay uh we called you in because
we got a bunch of questions
over the last two days the secretary of
homeland security my orcas has been
called up on capitol hill and they go
how many people are we letting in
exactly and he goes i i don't know they
go well how about a ballpark number i
can't even give a ballpark number the
white house was asked yesterday they
said we'll get the number to you later
this afternoon that was 18 hours ago
do they know the number
it's hard to believe that those numbers
are aren't being documented every
apprehension goes into the system every
release goes into the system
everything's cataloged so
for somebody to say that they have no
idea
i think it's a little disingenuous
rosindo where are they sending people
well who knows and and that's a problem
uh the initially the story was that
we're removing that we were having
extradition flights from the united
states to haiti and then all of a sudden
you hear that we're releasing them into
the interior of the united states and
they're giving them a notice to
respond instead of a notice to appear
which doesn't have the same legal weight
as a notice to appear so if somebody
doesn't show up to their court date or
their immigration
appointment then we can issue a warrant
or arrest for them with this notice to
respond
it's more like on good faith and
we've seen how that works out yeah
i think i've heard what only about 20
percent of people actually show up when
they're supposed to
well in the old days it was more like 95
that didn't show up so uh maybe maybe a
process has improved yeah so help me
understand
why is the administration playing dumb
with the numbers and not telling us
where they're putting people
well
that baffles me uh you know usually you
have an administration and we all have
different political philosophies on
whichever outside of the aisle you're on
but border security is not a political
issue border security should be
everybody's concern
these are people that are coming in and
these are the people that we're catching
we don't know what we're not catching uh
the people that we're catching you know
in this sector alone you've had over two
hundred thousand uh
i think uh hondurans uh you've only had
about eighty thousand mexican nationals
that have been apprehended here so we're
over 520 000 apprehensions in this
sector compared to less than 80 000 last
year so that's a what 500 and something
percent increase it's it's amazing the
amount of people
that are coming to the united states and
they're coming because we created the
magnet and the magnet is catch and
release and this is not a hard solution
uh i mean not it's not a hard problem to
solve the solutions very easy you detain
and you remove and you deliver
consequences and as a retired chief
rodney scott said a couple of days ago
when he submitted that letter to
congress is uh these these solutions
have been provided to the dhs hierarchy
and they just refuse to implement them i
think they want to do it their way but
their way as we see not working all
right rosando inohosa sir thank you very
much for your service and joining us on
this thursday morning
i just want to thank all the agents out
there doing the job uh keep the faith
and keep your heads up
well done well put sir thank you very
much
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now